[music playing]
Tonight on an epic
"Forged in Fire,"
Marvel's Midnight
Suns take over.
Jessie, Paul, gentlemen,
congratulations.
You are now vaulting into the
final round of this Marvel's
Midnight Suns competition.
In this final round, we're
sending you back to your home
forges to bring yet
another iconic weapon
from the Midnight Suns to life.
To tell you more
about that, I want
to introduce you to the
game's creative director,
Jake Solomon.
I am.
Bladesmiths, we are so
excited for this next build,
a weapon that has never
existed in the Marvel universe
before now.
Bladesmiths, you need to
go home and build this--
the Hunter's iconic blades.
[music playing]
Bladesmiths, this
pair of lethal swords
belongs to the Hunter,
an original superhero
that we created in close
partnership with Marvel.
The Hunter is the
first customizable
hero in the Marvel universe.
Bladesmiths, we are really
excited to see you bring
these virtual blades to life.
Good luck.
We will see you
here in four days.
[music playing]
My name is Paul
[inaudible],, Junior.
I'm from Livonia, Texas.
I'm 49 years old.
I served 22 years in the Army.
I run a program for vets
and first responders,
helping teach them
how to make knives.
If I were to be a superhero,
I would be Captain Damascus.
I'd take all their blades
and make them cooler.
I want to put my touch mark
on it as Captain Damascus.
So we're going to
make Damascus billets
with 80CrV2 and 15 and 20.
To tackle these brass guards,
I plan on using the mill.
All right, if I get
this milled, get
this handle material to sit in.
They're a little
difficult because they
are a matching set, one of them
being smaller than the other.
I still have to
quench my blades.
All right.
I'm ready to start
heat-treating.
Going in attack quench
is always scary.
You could always come
out with a crack, a warp.
This could be a major problem
for me this late in the game.
[intense music]
Oh, yeah.
Good and straight.
[music playing]
All right.
Two hard blades.
Looking good.
So as the clock
comes to an end, I
need to hurry and get the
paint rays put on the blades.
That's the best I can
do with what I got.
That's it for now
from Captain Damascus.
We'll see you back at the forge.
[music playing]
My name is Jessie Wipperman.
I'm 37 years old.
And I'm from Des Moines, Iowa.
And I've been bladesmithing
for about five years.
All of my kids
have tried forging,
but they realized how hot
it is, how dirty it is.
And they decided that playing
video games is more fun.
If I had a Marvel superhero
name, it would be the Foundry.
The Foundry's powers
melt the competition.
[laughs]
I decided to go
with mono steel 8670
because I feel like
spending more time,
making sure that the
handle is the best handle
the judges have ever seen.
I'm going to start
cutting the faux ivory
for my handles and the brass.
Now I'm just making sure that
everything pieces together
properly.
Biggest handle I've
ever done by far.
I'm going to be using the Dremel
to add some embellishments
on the brass guard and pommel.
I want the handles to
be the star of the show.
I'm excited to have the
judges test out my blades.
And I'm sure that they'll
cut through anything
that they put in front of it.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
Unfortunately, healing powers
is not my greatest suit,
but delegation of work is.
Wielding your weapons today
is my brother RJ Marquita.
[music playing]
Jessie, you're up first.
I am very proud of the blades
that I made going into testing.
I'm feeling pretty
confident right now.
[intense music]
All right, Jessie, both
your long and short sword
are very comfortable to wield.
They've got a very nice balance.
Now, your edges are very sharp.
They cut deeply into
the pig carcass.
Your weapons, sir,
they will kill.
Thank you.
Paul, your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
- I'll fire up the grill.
- All right.
We'll see you there.
[intense music]
I saw that he held
back [inaudible]..
All right, Paul.
First up for the long sword,
despite having the brass here,
and what I would think
is a counterbalance,
it is forward-heavy.
Now, where my hand is, right
above here on the handle,
it digs into your palm.
The shorter sword is much easier
to wield because the handle
matches nicely.
But these are deep cuts
on the pig carcass.
And overall, both of
your weapons will kill.
Thank you.
[music playing]
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the strength test.
[intense music]
To test the strength and
durability of your blades,
I'm going to be bashing
them into that big thing,
and also check
for edge retention
by cutting through
these bags and our jugs.
But I'm not going
to do this alone.
The Midnight Suns
work best as a team.
So I'm going to enlist the help
of my teammate, Dave Baker.
Jessie, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Give it hell.
All right.
[intense music]
All right, Jessie, man.
This is a beautiful set.
For the smaller sword, it
took some dinging on the edge,
but the weight is really nice.
Dave really enjoyed
swinging this one.
On the longer one, it took some
serious bending in the tests.
It's kicked off from the
handle, and then it kicks
back over at the tip there.
It was obviously sharp.
I mean, both of these swords
cut like they're supposed to.
But there's no getting
around this significant bend
in the larger one here.
All right, Paul.
You're up next.
Are you ready?
- Do it to it.
All righty.
[intense music]
All right, Paul.
So in Midnight Suns,
the video game,
Hunter carries these one in each
hand and uses them in battle.
And I don't know how long
I could swing this thing,
to be honest with you.
It's just got so
much mass to it.
And it's difficult to control.
Also, your edge on the small
one took quite a bit of packing.
It's quite dull here, which
changed the way that they cut.
They're just not the cleanest
cuts, but they do smash.
Nice shot.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, you started
off by making Blade's glaive
and ended with two
Hunter's iconic swords.
But in this competition,
only one of you
can come out on top as a
Forged in Fire Champion
of our Marvels
Midnight Suns takeover
and getting a check for $10,000.
Today's Forged in
Fire Champion is--
[intense music]
Jessie.
Congratulations.
Paul, you impressed the judges,
but fortunately your blades
did not make the cut.
And Ben is going
to tell you why.
Paul, the fit and
finish on your handles
is a little less refined
than your competitor.
That, coupled with the fact that
your long sword is extremely
heavy and difficult to wield,
and your short sword took
some damage in
the strength test,
are the reason we're
letting you go.
Well, Paul, it's been
a pleasure watching
you working this forge.
But unfortunately, at
this point in time,
I'm going to have
to ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
Thank you for having me.
Good job.
Jessie, congratulations.
That makes you the "Forged in
Fire" Champion of our Midnight
Suns competition take over.
And you'll be receiving
a check for $10,000.
[applause]
This whole experience
has been a blast.
And I would definitely
do it again.
Marvel theme, giant
demon things, the judges
are testing at the same
time, this is amazing.
[applause]
How do you feel?
- Speechless.
- Yeah?
I'm Jessie Wipperman.
And I'm a "Forged
in Fire" champion.
And it feels amazing.
[music playing]